die zweite folge habe ich weiß auch
nicht wieso ich stehe ja einfach so in
barfuß kataster man ich warte wie hoch
kaum ein breites könnten
willkommen bei einem video und ja ich
krieg ohne scheiß in letzter zeit so
viele nachrichten was weiß ich wo auf
fast das habe ich jetzt auch wieder
gelenk in der beschreibung ich finde ich
vorher dass gerade voll auf jeden fall
instagram facebook überall und von
irgendwelchen halt die fragen mich dann
so ja ich habe da so einen jungen aber
ich weiß nicht wie ich auf mich
aufmerksam machen soll da denke ich mir
ja gut
cookies video nein spaß aber auf jeden
fall ist gibt wirklich so viele so viele
leute die die ich weiß nicht warum ihn
beschreibt aber ich habe mir gedacht ja
okay wenn das wirklich so viele wissen
wollen es ist eigentlich ganz einfach
meiner meinung nach dann mache ich
einfach mal dieses video und es sind
auch nur fünf schritte ist eigentlich
ganz easy und ich würde sagen es geht
halt darum fünf schritte auf sich
aufmerksam zu machen fünf schritte ein
mädchen fünf schritte ein jungen zu
klären so eine art ja ich will auch gar
nicht lange dafür sagen wir sagen
einfach mal an falls euch gefällt den
daumen nach oben wäre natürlich immer
leist und viel spaß also wir leben ja
nicht mehr so 1960 oder 70 oder so
bewusst sei noch kein internet gab auf
jeden fall aber jetzt instagram facebook
diese ganze kleine rataj diese gerne
diese ganzen social networks und das ist
eigentlich so der startpunkt der
wirklich das ganze ziemlich vereinfacht
wenn ihr zum beispiel mädchen oder ein
junge ist eigentlich scheißegal und
nennen jungen habt oder halt mädchen dem
ihr so cool findet oder dass sie so ganz
hübsch findet und ja irgendwie muss man
halt so auf sich aufmerksam machen in
kontakt kommen und da er heutzutage fast
jeder mensch facebook oder instagram hat
und auch ein profil hat wolf vielleicht
das ein oder andere foto hochlädt dann
kann man vielleicht einfach auf das
profil gehen und läuft einfach mal so
fünf sechs fotos das ist wirklich eine
sache die die klappt eigentlich immer
denn wirklich jeder normale mensch jetzt
nicht gerade 30 40 50 tausend follower
zieht das auto nimmt das wirklich wahr
und jeder normale mensch weiß auch dann
okay die person finden wir schon ganz
attraktiv sag ich mal so und wenn dann
halt von dieser person von der ihr so
ein paar bilder gelegt habt ein zwei
drei oder vielleicht sogar zehn likes
zurückkommen könnt ihr davon ausgehen
dass ihr euch auch cool findet mir ist
mein folger
weiß auch nicht wieso ich stehe einfach
so in barfuß katastrophe wie im mai ja
auf jeden fall kommt man dann zum
nächsten schritt das wildlife schritt
eins jetzt kommt schritt zwei ist
eigentlich ganz einfach
anschreiben weil ihr braucht euch darauf
wirklich dann überhaupt keine sorgen
machen dass versicherer ich euch wenn
von der person auch leicht zurückkommen
auf 56 fotos dann kennt die wenig davon
ausgehen dass diese person auch geil
findet deswegen denkt er gar nicht lange
nach und findet er mich jetzt wirklich
holt sondern schreibt einfach an und
fertig so was weiß ich dann schreibt er
halt bei facebook insta direkt oder
videos heiß was wenn ich was sonst noch
alles gibt schreibt man halt so ein
bisschen schreibt halt ein zwei drei
tage so ganz normal und weisen schreiben
kommen wir dann auch schon direkt zu
schritt 3 bzw schritt 4
und zwar ist das auch eigentlich ganz
einfach wie vielleicht ist da am anfang
komisch so beschreibt aber das ist
wirklich wichtig ihr müsst so denn wenn
diese person so keine ahnung ein
bisschen ich hab das zum beispiel dass
so einer situation umgehen das sagt
jetzt besser nicht grüßen dich auf jeden
fall wenn diese person so bestimmte
interessen hat oder irgendwelche
interesse hat ihr müsst so selbst wenn
es euch nicht ganz so interessiert aber
eigentlich schon sodann dann müsst ihr
also ein bisschen drauf eingehen und so
tun als würde auch interessieren weil
dann zeigt diese zeigt ihr dieser person
dass hier wirklich so interessant zeit
eigentlich und dann kommen wir auch
schon zum schritt 4
der kommt dann so nach ein zwei tagen
würde ich sagen und zwar das ist
wirklich so da denkt man so am anfang
vielleicht wenn man jetzt so 14 oder 15
ist wie viele von euch halt dann soll
ich das jetzt wirklich so schreiben
kommt das vielleicht ein bisschen blöd
auf jeden fall meine ich damit ganz
einfach schreiben so was wie ihr
irgendwas von aufwenden jung ist
schreibt einfach irgendwas von süß oder
so das hört man jetzt als junge zwar
nicht ganz so gerne aber viele jungs
habe ich doch und deswegen schreibt
einfach wenn ihr euch über irgendwelche
fotos oder so unterhaltung von leben
oder dem was ich weiß ja nicht mal
schreibt über so viel scheiße wenn man
wirklich mit einer person viel schreibt
schreibt einfach so dazu oder ja voll
süß oder computer wie mädchen deshalb
schreiben oder dieses ab
was weiß ich was das bedeutet auf jeden
fall schildert er für so was glaube ich
das kommt auch mal wirklich gut also
dass ja so so ich finde das hat
eigentlich voll einfach soja sojasauce
soja wenn ihr dann halt so wenn ihr dann
halt so ein bisschen geschrieben habt
vielleicht fünf sechs tage woche oder so
ein wirklich jeden tag so keine ahnung
euch die ganze zeit schreibt dann könnt
ihr wirklich davon ausgehen dass ja dass
das hier so interesse aneinander habt
euch mal wollen normalerweise ja ich
weiß die meisten mädchen denken an soja
vom jungen dieser schritt auf gehen ob
man sich mal treffen will oder halt
nicht ja ja ja also ich sehe das jetzt
nicht so als warum sollte der junge
immer fragen ob man sich treffen gibt
das fernsehen auf jeden fall das habe
ich gerade auch glaube ich schon gesagt
wenn man länger schreibt und wirklich
den ganzen tag schreibt dann braucht ihr
euch überhaupt keine gedanken machen
dass bei dem anderen vielleicht kein
interesse da ist euch zu treffen weil
bei mir war das so ich weiß jetzt nicht
ihr seid wahrscheinlich so zum großteil
zwischen 12 und 17 ich sehe das ja wenn
ihr halt so 14.15 seite in diesem alter
dann der gegenüber freut sich wirklich
darüber mache mir überhaupt keine
gedanken macht das einfach und vertraut
mir selbst das mädchen seit und ist
eigentlich scheißegal der junge freut
sich wirklich auf jeden fall und ihr
müsst halt nicht denken ja das ist der
muss das machen weil sonst ist geht das
nicht fragt einfach nach dem treffen das
wäre halt der fünfte schritt und das
klappt dann eigentlich zu 95 prozent
ja das war so meinem ein nein das machen
viele ja ich habe das auch mitbekommen
als auch mit es gibt auch sehr viele
personen die das so machen
instagram es super dafür er ohne scheiß
jetzt trails nicht hier so instrument
zur partnerbörse machen hat sich klasse
genauso wie die st
lecker lecker ja heute von euch würde
ich ohne scheiß kenner wissen wenn ihr
das mal ausprobieren oder so oder wenn
ich es auch schon ausprobiert habt so
diese diese variante oder diese abfolge
dann schreib doch mal in die kommentare
wie das so verlaufen ist es wird mich
echt mega interessieren oder generell
was ihr davon haltet und ja sonst würde
ich sagen doch nach oben wer immer geil
instagram packe ich euch nochmal in die
video beschreibung war auch eben schon
ein gebinde genauso wie snap chat das
habe ich jetzt auch ist mega meister
post immer ohne scheiß viele videos und
hier auf der linken seite geht es weiter
mit meinem letzten video das war fame
werden ganz easy so ironie auf jeden
fall und hier auf der anderen seite
lasst euch überraschen
checkt auf jeden fall bis 8 die video
das in berlin sind am samstag ich freue
mich den freitag schon ich freue mich
mega und sowieso richtig viele mal
wieder von euch zu sehen und drei leute
wir sehen uns am wochenende zschau